so general I just want to go back over
it again because here's this weird thing
that happens um I used to think when I
first became a teacher right I think man
I wish I was like one of those super
experienced teachers because then I
would know everything really well I
think I can just explain it without
thinking and I sort of lived up to them
and realized oh this is something I'm
longing for about it's gonna be many
years until I get there and then I
realized actually there's something
dangerous that happens that teachers
when they get old and I don't know if
you've noticed it before or maybe it's
not your experience at all
not only do they get the order on you
know tired and cynical and like a thing
but also because they get so good at
what they're doing and what they're
teaching then they forget what it's like
to not know these things or they forget
what it's like for this to be new
because it's just they're been teaching
for decades right so I thought to myself
okay I gave you a bit of an introduction
to this yesterday but I was determined
to come up with a better way of
explaining it one which would be a
little more memorable and you guys
already know that I'm fond of corny
acronyms so I've come up with one to try
and work you through this and it took me
like a whole 45 minutes I think of it
because I had I knew I had two letters
in the middle I had to use and it turned
out to be very uncommon in English words
so I'll show it to you and then I'll let
you be the judge whether it's any good
or not okay so here's the kind of
question we're looking at before explain
what the acronym is and you'll remember
the reason why we going into chain rule
is just for these kinds of examples we
can differentiate this we can work with
it if we just expand everything out but
as these powers get very large that
becomes impractical okay so therefore we
wanted a way of our prettiness which
avoided expanding okay so I said is the
chain rule and he's my way of
remembering there are four steps to
chain rule okay and here my way he's my
way of remembering with the four steps
up okay so I don't know how you connect
a chain rule to a riot but anyway give
it a go if you can't something
James you're right riots on that hot to
remember right um what's the first step
for you upstairs for Wyatt okay so the
first letter no no the order actually
does matter in this the first time since
we replace okay so this is my lipstick
your way of saying introduce a
substitution right that's what we're
really doing do you remember that okay
so the first thing I'm gonna do is say
let's do and that was the thing we're
gonna replace with this function in here
okay because we said we're gonna
function and it's being applied to
another function okay I want to do is
put a function and function okay so I'm
going to let u equal this okay so if
that's the case then that implies that Y
is equal to just you the power of eight
is that okay so there's my replacement
there's my first step okay so there's
this now what's my second step I did
have to look at these two functions the
inside function and the outside function
act is differentiate both of them okay
so here's my first one the inside one so
I'll take do you on DX
okay which in this case is 2x plus 3
okay so there's the first derivative the
derivative of the inside function okay
and then I look at the outside function
which is just u to power right so dy on
D U is equal to eight U to the 7th so
there is my outside function okay now
what's my last step this is where the
chain of the chain rule comes in okay
I've got my two derivatives now what I
want to do is put them together okay
so there's there's my team right what
does the chain look like if you take the
derivative bit you're after do you want
yet okay
and then you string together the other
derivatives you've got in that chain
right there dy on to you the times do
you 1dx okay so that's going to be 8 u
to the 7 2x plus 3 and then you remember
we introduced you to help us solve the
question or we don't actually want you
in our solution okay
so therefore substitute it back in front
what it actually is tada okay sir that
was riot ok there they go that's that's
it
channel is not that complicated okay at
least when you start off where it gets
really tricky is when you start to
issues different kinds of functions when
you look at tree and logs and
Exponential's for instance you'll get to
learn how to do this
differentiate a function like this or
differentiate a function like this and
so on and so forth okay so when you've
got different kinds of combinations like
these or something like how do they
different kinds of combinations of
families of functions
that's where chain rule gets to be
really fun okay